décidément en 2019 l'humour est devenu
plus que jamais un sujet qui fait débat
et qui est de plus en plus objet à
polémique
nouvel exemple en date les réactions
très violentes après une blague de jean
marie bigard dans tpm paix le 11 février
dernier alors invité de l'émission
l'humoriste s'était risqué à une
dernière blague avant laquelle il avait
précisé jean marie ne croyait pas si
bien dire car après cette plaisanterie
de signature de l'humoriste depuis 30
ans les réactions ne se sont pas fait
attendre
après de nombreux messages virulents sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est une nouvelle
étape qui a été franchie hier jean marie
bigard en effet annoncé sur son compte
facebook 50 dates de sa tournée avait dû
être annulée suite à cette plaisanterie
je suis détruit je devais faire la
tournée var matin
cet été 49 dates s'étaient tous m'ont
été de travail et je viens d'apprendre
il ya trois quarts d'heure là que
j'étais viré en fait étonnamment jean
marie bigard avait fait exactement la
même blague sur le plateau de thé pmp
six ans plus tôt jean-marie bigard perd
donc 50 dates à cause de cette blague
alors choqué ou pas choquer
alors jean marie bigard acte avec jean-
marié c'est qu'on peut voir en vue
d'avoir votre avis là-dessus
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
que cette tournée a été annulée pour
jean marie bigard merci les amis alors
vous êtes tous choqués c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable dit c'est non
franchement s'accroissant pas les signes
en henry mais on peut même pas rigoler
alors les gars on le connaît on sait
pourquoi enlèvement c'est pourquoi c'est
une star c'est une star de l'humour
voilà il a fait de l'humour maintenant
comment on annule ça c'est incroyable
comme j'ai dit là dans la foi c'est vrai
que voilà la blague et moi jean marie
cohen fait dit un autre fois sur dix
c'est blake sont drôles voilà il y en a
une qui passait à côté
voilà c'est après que ça ait pu blesser
des gens et c'est vrai que voilà on peut
comprendre et jean-marie comprends mais
c'est vrai qu'après cela ait des
conséquences comme ça pour lui des
conséquences financières que vous dire
des dramatiques et conséquences vraiment
pour lui pour sa carrière et pour pour
l'artiste que c'est dramatique aussi
faut pas oublier tout ce qui apporte et
mine de rien jean marie à notre pays a
fait ce qu'il a apporté à la france et
jean marie c'est un humaniste et j'en
arrive je vous le dis je le redis il
c'est un garçon qui respecte vraiment
profondément les femmes
alors forcément on peut pas tout dire on
peut pas faire des blagues surtout on a
on en a conscience
en direct et je pense que jean marie on
a conscience aussi mais mine de rien que
ça prenne de telles proportions moi ça
me fait de la peine pour lui parce que
c'est un pote et parce que je le connais
et que je sais que jean marie c'est un
mec vraiment qu'ils respectent la gente
féminine et qui respecte les femmes
comme comme très peu et voilà c'est
franchement c'est injuste que si mme
coakley du csa justement juste vous en
pensez juste un mot pour dire que le
théâtre n'est pas la télé
la télé on peut condamner effectivement
les propos qui ont été dits la dernière
fois sur ce plateau on peut les mois et
années ils ont été dits aussi sur rtl il
a l'habitude et c'est de dire sur
d'autres plateaux on peut le condamner
sur une chaîne sur une radio mais dans
un spectacle je suis choqué dans un
spectacle où les gens viennent et
réservent leurs places
on connaît jean marie bigard depuis 40
ans je suis très choqué de voir que
cette voie là c'est deux poids deux
mesures c'est ma rien à voir merci merci
les uns et je le dis et je vous lire
jean marie gillain faut donc je ne peux
pas ne peut pas dire que ma d'infos mais
j'ai une info je sais qu'il va vous
remplacez et qui va faire les dates à
votre place notamment un jeu vous lire
dans un style génial dit long je voulais
me voilà
ils vous ont remplacé sur les dates oui
ce qui est fou c'est que la sanction est
totalement délirante enfin c'est d'une
violence c'est de la censure aussi donc
c'est double mandat le voilà doublement
scandaleux alors on va voir que
maintenant
bon maintenant il nous reste j'aimerais
dans la vie de ben ali revealing connais
bien jean marie faye a dépeint la radio
c'est parce que je vois là c'est sûr
reconnaît même jean-marie depuis
l'époque de tf1 on avait fait tellement
démission ensemble et je sais à quel
point c'est un garçon qui est absolument
délicieux et notamment avec les femmes
et il ne dit pas et je ne sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs il ne le dit pas
peut-être par pudeur et par enfin voilà
parce que c'est un garçon qui ne dit pas
les choses qu'il fait il fait énormément
il fait des choses pour des associations
pour des notes amende et associations de
femmes et dans des pays étrangers et il
ne l'a pas il ne le dit pas là en son
temps nécessaire de dire regardez mais
non c'est pas vrai je suis un amoureux
des femmes je fais si je fais ça il dit
juste non voilà non je voudrais
simplement travailler moi je connais cet
homme là et je sais à quel point ça on
va laisser jean marie bigard jean marie
v dites nous ce que vous avez à nous
dire soyez aux élus juge-t-elle j'ai été
cunnilingus d'argent à montréal soit
échoue pinette de bronze à séoul alors
en 2002 jean-marie fait que vous êtes
très pénibles parce que je suis très
peiné mais moins ce soir tu sais
pourquoi parce que je viens d'entendre à
la sens et par ces petits écriteaux qui
viennent à mon secours
tu sais quoi en quelques heures j'ai eu
un million de vues de gens qui venaient
à mon secours
donc j'ai envie de dire merci
jean-marc pastorino qui est l'organe de
la bavarde oncle le patron de var matin
il m'a châtié et je pense que c'est pas
possible d'abord pour les varoises et
les varois qui m'adorent j'allais faire
rire pendant 59 date c'était cool le mec
me vire avec un seul et unique argument
qui est à mon avis doit pouvoir passer
sous le coup de la loi
c'est de dire on peut pas prendre un mec
qui a raconté la blague de la déchirure
à la télé qui est ce mec qui peut dire
tout d'un coup je n'ai
le ski n'a pas reçu des pressions
jean-marie peut-être c'est peut-être je
sais pas il est ce qu il a du mal dans
sa peau
d'ailleurs en ce moment ce pauvre jean
marc pastorino j'ai de la peine pour lui
parce que toute la journée n'a pas
arrêté de dire nous n'avions pas de
contrat mais on n'est pas deux contre un
mais on avait des emails et tout le truc
était bouclée entièrement par e-mail ça
veut dire en fait j'ai c'est une rupture
de d'engagement juste devant marie ce
que tu penses que c'est vraiment lui le
responsable
est ce que tu penses pas que c'est moi
je pense en voilà qu'il a dû avoir
beaucoup de pression sur les réseaux
sociaux sur ses mails sur 7 sur son
entourage voilà mais toi qu'est c'est à
dire ce soir jean-marie parce que nous
on est on ne paie ni par ce qui t'arrive
voilà vire au téléspectateur est ce qui
nous reste une minute
voilà on voulait absolument avoir compté
mon âge ce soir et mon témoignage c'est
de dire ce pauvre jean marc qu'il n'est
pas de couilles ce peut arriver tu vas
mais il n'a pas d'humour non plus et les
deux ensembles c'est mortel côté un pote
si tu as un pote cas pas de couilles et
pas d'humour tu var du mal à l'emmener
avec bernard mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce et c'est très important les
humoristes nous on est là pour justement
faire rire en chat corps mari gênant tu
le fais paris iap iap iap l'inde
humoristiques ont soutenu aussi mine de
rien il ya plein d'humoristes qui t'ont
soutenu bien sur presque tous j'ai reçu
un message de briques sébastien et il
m'a dit la lâcheté des gens quittent
attaque c'est le prix de notre liberté
m'a dit jean-marie et il joue là à dire
aussi il me supprime le bec
malheureusement c'est un scoop avec une
amie de 33 ans muriel robin n'ont rien
de robin donc c'est alès book mais avec
eva darlan bigard doit être puni elle
est disparue du mauss unis tu m'entends
poussant son apologie de la violence
et moi je lui dis mais muriel c'est pas
toi c'est pas mon ami de 33 ans qui dit
ça tu sais ce que je fais ce don ce
qu'évoquait tout à leur mobile
oui c'est valérie mais elle me dit le
nom mais c'est ça et alors
et je vous raconte la conversation parce
qu'elle est drôle et je lui dis est au
sketch sur le noir qui n'est pas venu
dans une famille de blancs mais dis moi
il est noir une loi où il est un petit
peu blanc je lui dis est ce que ça
serait pas l'apologie du racisme
et tu sais ce qu elle me répond elle me
dit messier c'est la mère qui parle
c'est pas moins un personnage que jiwa
ouais c'est moi je suis pas le docteur
conclut la dame dont l'une en apparence
[Applaudissements]
la dame n'existe pas non plus c'est une
blague
oui tu vois alors ça peut être une
mauvaise blague voilà moi je pense avoir
eu le pire jour et ce serait qu'elle ne
fasse pas rire oui voilà les deux là
j'entre en larmes
mais par contre si on a encore le droit
de rire même du pire
une vrai qu'on est sauvé sinon on est
perdu merci jean marie bigard d'abord à
calais merci à tous avec leur mari on
espère que ça va s'arranger
est ce que dis je crois que cela vient
aussi je crois que c'est liane foly qui
va faire la tournée passe bien je suis
très heureux aux lionnes qui est le vrai
je ne serai jamais on aime beaucoup mais
la naksa foot voilà c'est le nous les
humoristes on reçoit et tous vous le
diront on reçoit la sempiternelle
question des journalistes
est ce que on peut rire de tout oui et c
c'est faut rendre à césar c'est benoît
delépine et gustave kerven de ont fait
la réponse universelle que je salue je
les embrasse ils ont répondu on ne peut
rire que de tous merci jean marie garcia
[Applaudissements]